every August 40,000 rabid country music
fans descend on burles Creek just north
of Toronto they are joined by the
biggest stars country music has to offer
together they create the nation's the
largest celebration of all things
country
this is et Canada boots and hearts
brought to you by Chevy music coming
home yeah you know I mean it's the it's
like country music Christmas this is the
biggest day of the year for Canadian
country artists as a whole huge festival
going on take a city out there yeah the
people here is become such a piece of
mouth we're devoted to them and they're
devoted up it's like one of those
vessels we hear about all the time of
the United States it's you know just as
big over there is any a festival there
are are bigger festivals they're
switching hearts at that level I all my
buddies will come down and do I call
dude you got blue boots and heart
I'd say it's just more of a party
atmosphere around and that's I like that
this is a everyday thing for us so but I
had to say man this one here is a little
different we love this decimal isn't
like one of my favorite things to play
just because the fans are so passionate
I mean anybody who can plot here in camp
for three days and I mean those are the
fans you want your name yeah that's how
you wanna play
the festival kicks off with the Chevy
Music presents boots and hearts emerging
artists showcase as eight artists
compete for a chance to achieve their
dreams now that we're finally at Boots
it is so exciting
incredible what an opportunity for
artists like myself and seven others in
the competition we get to play one of
the biggest country music festivals in
Canada
it's my dream I came here last year as a
fan it's just the greatest form of
payment you don't get these kinds of
chances every day you literally get this
gentle watch you know the bull when you
sees red and he's got that back foot
going that's gonna be me up those stairs
when it's my turn to get out there I
can't wait man it feels so amazing to be
performing at boots and hurts I've been
dreaming about this for so long I've
waited for this opportunity for so long
especially to perform on a huge stage
like that it's hard to be standing in
front of your dream and knowing that
you're about to walk into it but you got
to focus on doing a show it's a really
hard thing to master
I'm super excited and my fingers are
cross and I go out there and put on a
great performance and hopefully I get
Texas I'm playing on a stage it's a lot
bigger than we've ever played up like
two more people don't remember played to
and I think we're just kind of trying to
make it more exciting I have an absolute
blast on stage I have a good time I want
to make sure the audience has a good
time at the end of the day it's all
about making sure the crowd is happy
they want to see more so I try and give
them that tonight the best adrenaline
rush you could ever think oh I cannot
express enough how grateful I am to
Chevy music for taking something up you
know it's kind of a hobby of mine and
really making it something I could do
for the rest of my life
[Applause]
it's just
[Applause]
yeah Jay's right baby foods and 2016 is
like country music is expanding it turns
into sound do you think that like the
boundaries of question like a little
mass acts like the reason I'm a Nestle
yeah I don't know what's country wants
not anymore I really don't care I just
love making music I love making my music
so these people complain insane he's not
country shouldn't be there he did it
yeah so stop being jealous yeah just
enjoy the music eyes on you first of all
or would that feel like
we waited six long years to of touring
of writing and put music out to to get a
number one it was awesome it was awesome
for me it was awesome for the crew we
fought for it and and now we got to do
it again
what advice did you have for artists
that are trying to get that big break
food I would say just stick to being
yourself so don't try to be some don't
try to be Sam hunt
don't try to be Thomas Rhett don't try
to be me like Trek just stick to
yourself but then put real it for me
like what I've really learned a lot
lately is just pushing myself to I Know
Who I am now as an artist I know what
I'm doing with my music but I'm also
pushing the edge and I'll go into it
right and I'll be like yeah that doesn't
sound like something I would do but
let's try it and see what happens and
then it's up to you to put it out I mean
you know nobody's gonna hear it if you
don't want them to but if you're great
and you just keep going eventually we'll
get this show up yeah show up every time
play doesn't matter if it's the if it's
the stage outside the toilet
you know like play every play the side
stage never be too big to go and show
off what you know who you are in your
artistry and and just yeah if you show
up to win showing ups half the battle we
just played Europe for the first time oh
yeah and we played I did seven shows in
three days Wow and because we were is
our first time there and I told him I
want to play everything I want to play a
side stage I want to play the main so I
want to do it all I want to hit as maybe
these three days as impactful as
possible you know I would just say just
be present and if show up and just be be
proud to be part of the breath and the
grind never stops right never stops man
it's like you think it does everybody
present man if I could just get that out
yeah I just get a bus good and then you
get the bus you're like all mate if I
good - yes oh yeah every level has it
has a certain type of sub that you
that's easier but then it comes with a
southern part of struggles as well you
know so the grind never stops you know
you're never gonna master it which is a
cool part of it you just get better
sitting at a picnic table or runaway
June and the country music vessel
doesn't get more country music than this
so what's like being at boots and hearts
it's awesome this is our second year and
last year that this is the first time we
ever played in Canada it'll be so hard
splash there so and it was so fun and
now we're on the main stage so it's
really exciting
[Applause]
so you're sunk having all the success of
course Mary Morris a song girl just went
number one as well you see a shift
happening like does it seem like there's
more female representation of country
radio now I don't think that it will
ever be what it used to be but with a
little bit of a change you know who
knows where it can go but I do feel that
there's a shift happening it's it's just
great to be a part of it and know that
like if we get into you know the top
five someone else can get into so I
think there's definitely a change
happening for sure even look at today
there's three female acts on the main
stage that's crazy like I don't think I
don't remember the last time I've been a
part of a festival that had that had
that many females on the main stage
what advice would you have for those
kind of artists trying to get their big
break all I know is like from us and all
the artist friends that we have it's
like there's so many people that at some
point we're like this is it I'm giving
up like no more keeping with your nose
so much and then something keeps them
going and then the tide shift and then
they get their opportunity so it's like
you just have to keep going and like
working on your craft because it's you
just never know when
it's gonna happen one day here we have
the nothing to do town EP that's the
note for a little bit you must know like
what's it been like to like play these
songs to fans like you surprised it like
a certain song that's really the grab
people you know the whole thanks
surprise for me I mean there was a time
when I released music and nobody cared
nothing they care they just didn't know
they didn't know who I was anything the
now I couldn't release the song rock at
least some EP and they learned the songs
and they show up to the show and they
stream the song back to the other side
that's that's cool that's like that's
the reason I write music and go out
there and perform music
the time I was a little kid I know I
wanted to play music and perform music
and write music and so when it was
finally working like oh we're having 25
20 15 10 ha
I do at top pile about to be number one
are you kidding me like that's what we
that's what we do it for you know so it
was it was surreal there's so many paths
you can go down to get a big break you
know there's so many ways you can do it
but I mean just me myself you know my do
was I moved to Nashville and I met the
right people and started writing my
music and learning my hardest tree and I
started playing shows there
I started busting it on the road playing
250 people than a hundred people then
just grow and it slowly and surely and
so here we are you know 10 years since I
moved to Nashville and they were finally
getting somewhere so that was my path
you know that's just the way it you just
gotta work it is what it is you never
know it could happen next week it might
take six seven years just just grind it
out coming up Kip Moore Tim Hicks and
the finale of the Chevy music presents
boots and hearts emerging artists
showcase brought to you by Chevy music
proudly supporting emerging artists
[Music]
this is et Canada at boots and hearts
2019
brought to you by Chevy music and the
party is in full swing as the Sun rises
on Saturday at boots and hearts with a
surprise pop-up concert in the
campground want to give a little bit of
background like it's 2015 you're in the
top two yes other seven music boots and
hearts emerging artists showcase yes now
what happened after that unfortunate
didn't end up winning and so I was
bummed the next day I just got out of
school I was bartending and I was
delivering pizzas it was an interesting
week very humbling but I I took a
picture of the the crowd that day and I
just sort of ever since I used that as
like you know a goal I wanted to be back
on this stage but not as part of a
contest wanting to be invited back as an
artist I think it's pretty obvious when
the place you've having people read what
would you say to those finalists whether
you win or lose it's it's you know I say
hard work beats talent when talent
doesn't work hard so hard work even
after after whatever happens tomorrow
what's gonna get you where you want to
go is the amount of hard work you put in
when you decide to keep a song for
yourself or give away like you're gonna
waste songs like Florida Georgia line
Chris Lane yeah like where do you decide
like you know I'm gonna keep through
this one people ask me that a lot and
it's really I really have no good answer
for it it's just like you just kind of
know that it's a song for you now I'm in
like this weird situation like I have a
record done but I'm like still writing
songs but I'm just like man this would
be great but I'm not gonna put another
record out for two years so it's just
like let's let somebody else have it if
they want
groans - right now who combs yeah so
what's it like kind of watching him do
his thing he's not being anything other
than himself
he wears the Columbia shirt camouflage
hat blue jean I mean he's not trying to
be anything other than that and people
love it that's probably the biggest
thing I learned growing just just be
yourself and they can work would you
have the places who are trying to figure
out this country music thing man I mean
you got to have a little talent and you
got a catch breaks this industry is this
you know I mean I mean one bad like one
show or it's like people don't seem
interested I'm just like that's it I'm
not this didn't meant to be for me and
then then I like a show last night in
Detroit there was a couple hundred
people in the clip singing every word to
some girls and I'm just like all right
we're dude we're like making an impact
here so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your process light for wedding
songs I usually like every morning get
up like think of something that I've
been going through maybe I have it in
put it in my phone or something and I'll
try to think of a title or a hook around
that idea and then I'll bring that into
a writing room and hopefully try to
write that
what advice would you have for us
they're trying to get that big break or
trying to get noticed in the country
music scene make trips down to Nashville
and then just write songs try to get
into room then go to writers around and
just be surrounded by the best of the
best and that'll make you better
[Music]
[Applause]
in Canada I know what its gonna be like
every time we walk out walk out there
how it's gonna be I'm telling you that I
that you're post later on we're going to
be talking the Kip war and then everyone
is waiting for Miranda Lambert
Rock would be stage tonight I know who
the people are excited to see on there
I'm just like okay that's good that's
good let you know man now once I quit
this new song she's mine yeah but you've
had this song for like ten years yeah
hold on to this why I've been holding on
to it for so well I mean we tried to
record it for the Wild Ones record and
we just missed them are plain and simple
when I pulled it back up eight years
later in the dressing room and I'm
playing it on my acoustic guitar and the
fact that my my band has only heard the
song maybe twice in their whole life
they remember all of it you know and it
was just most things where even they
were like you're crazy not or try to
record this now the album is coming we
know is it completely done
I got one song left to go report we're
looking to release the album in January
okay what advice would you have for
artists custom yeast artists trying to
get their big break for me personally
it was all about through these years
it's been about conviction from day one
you know the minute the Sam hunt blew up
he was doing what he was doing his own
thing his thing was given to anybody
else and I always tell how hard it's
like are you gonna want to play this
song in 20 years is this song still
gonna be cool to sing in 20 years and I
think if you can say yes then you might
have something coming out Tim Hicks
comes home to boots and hearts the two
emerging artists will leave it all on
the main stage brought to you by Chevy
music proudly supporting emerging
artists this is et Canada at boots and
hearts 2019 brought to you by Chevy
music it's Sunday morning and while it's
quiet now for David boy James and Justin
Tyler the fourth day of boots could be
the day their lifelong dreams come true
[Music]
now I want you back
[Music]
such a great platform with Chevy Medusa
harness I guess who started I think it's
such a great momentum to kind of keep
things going it we're really excited we
got a lot of things going on and and you
know this we're just starting to get the
ball rolling we got a lot coming for
pop up back up the show music truck and
the RV campground what was that like
dude it was awesome man this is our
first performance in Canada
[Music]
we won't
[Music]
so that was kind of the first taste of
like holy crap I have fans here and you
know in the morning on a Sunday morning
yeah yeah it's cool man you walk up
there and and I'm playing these songs
acoustic and I'm seeing everybody
singing them and I'm just like man I
can't believe I gotta have fans up here
and it's just it's surreal that's always
like what's up feeling like the see
people singer lyrics back to you it's
very hard to process
yeah especially in the moment
[Applause]
so what the festival life like for you
like I said how is it different for
mature feels a little bit more like
summer camp just the backstage area and
I think it's really cool you never know
that you're gonna be on a festival bill
with and I think
you find the crowd is different at a
festival you get a different energy and
usually there may be like a little more
drunk early so they're feisty
it's not like by like 2:30 right now
y'all need to slow down they're not
gonna make it
what's the best piece of ice that you
got as upcoming artists Blake Shelton
once told me when I was on tour with him
you need to find five things and when
people say your name they immediately
think of and can identify us and I
really try to implement that into my
artistry as I went forever can you say
those five things or any of the things
that I mean I would say dolly Dollywood
90s country red wine you know I mean
things like that
[Music]
[Music]
giggling I remember you're part of the
seventh using emerging artists showcase
well so seven years ago so what advice
would you have for the finalists that
are doing it yes I think just be
yourself people will often assume that I
want it I didn't win it but and and
that's just proof that you don't have to
win a contest to have a career in music
but just be yourself that resonates with
you go do what you do and just hope that
you do it the best that you can do on
that in that moment you know it's a it's
a pretty nerve-racking you know clinch
your cheeks together and go kind of a
thing well but it's exciting too so
enjoy every minute of it soak it up but
also keep doing it after the soap oh
absolutely
now right yeah it's just a great
opportunity for an up-and-comer to come
in and get some great exposure and it's
such a great vibe to be a part of a
festival like this because it doesn't
get any bigger in Canada
[Music]
now we're just put a month away from the
Kennedy Country Music Awards for
nominations yep yeah fans choice and
album to me very flattering like that
and you know I never thought in my
wildest dreams that I would ever be
recognized in that way it helps to keep
the train going know and as we say we
always joking the band's like we're
gonna ride this thing till it the wave
hits the beach buddy in doing so
enjoying every second of it so we just
days like today we really soak it in
boots and hearts began with eight
emerging artists chasing a dream now the
two finalists take to the stage to find
out who will win the Chevy Music
presents boots and hearts emerging
artists showcase and see their dreams
realized to know that I'm this close to
walking up Isetta stairs that could put
me out in front of the thirty thousand
country bands
it's pretty damn special shaman at the
beach
get ready ready for good time
get ready ready for good that was
awesome that was awesome
the dream that I've been chasing for the
last 12 years of my life is coming to
reality everybody
[Music]
the winner this year of our emerging
artists Showcase is David boy ten guys
from the bottom of my heart thank you so
much
and for all the country fans out there
I've been dreaming to do this can I get
a hell yeah
[Applause]
brought to you by chevy music proudly
supporting emerging artists
[Music]
as et Canada at boots and hearts 2019
brought to you by Chevy music draws to a
close
David boy Jane's soaking in his victory
thank you so much heavy music returning
my passion into a profession I can
finally say I'm a recording artist
[Applause]
[Music]
you